you know I rant about Monday and you
hating it and we've had iconic videos
I'm sure they're doing something now
that's how they roll about that
situation I mean you know the real the
real question I've been debating is how
do I tell you what to do okay cool I'll
yell at you and say if you hate your
Monday then you've got to change and you
only have one life this and that and
people like but what do I do what are
the steps I think one of the biggest
steps is just a break patterns right
like you just have to call out tomorrow
you have to call out Tuesday we have to
create a call out on Tuesday and you
need to do something you either need to
go to some Goodwill stores buy some
stuff and post it on eBay like we've
talked about you need to reach out to
5,000 people on Twitter that day that
you admire and ask them if you can have
a cup of coffee we've talked about that
some of you've successfully done that
with me and Mark Cuban and the craziest
entrepreneurs and famous people in the
world so maybe that's what you do maybe
on your call out Tuesday you go and go
to six interviews for different jobs
that you've been holding off maybe on
your call out Tuesday you know you go
and visit your grandmother or your dad
and have that conversation that you've
needed to have whether that's I love you
or whether that's hey I'm not going to
be pinned down by your negativity
anymore I'm going to do it you know
motivation is exciting but the
practicality of an execution is even
more importantly and so I sit here today
and I make this video and I say it's a
call out Tuesday call out of work
tomorrow do not go to school tomorrow do
not do what you normally do tomorrow if
you hated today's Monday if you hated
waking up today if you loved the weekend
if you can't wait for Friday and do one
of those four or five things that I just
told you or the reverse or the reverse
once you take your kids out of school
your kids are not gonna remember fourth
grade Tuesday English class but taking
them somewhere just you guys doing
something fun is something they'll
remember forever
that's what I want to do with this video
I want to inspire a call-out Tuesday
then action I don't want to hear that
you slept in to 11:30 and just mope
around and ate some fruity pebbles
action that we just talked about or
something else leave a comment below
with what you're gonna do on your
call-out Tuesday
Wow